[Music]
last time I talked to you we got into a
discussion and you mentioned that your
all time acting hero is Nicolas Cage
yeah you love Nicolas play like him and
so it's curious there's a new Ghost
Rider
yes movie that's coming out and I'm just
curious he are you gonna see this movie
no I can't I can't do it anymore I just
I went up to Bangkok dangerous I got
past the crazy title and his crazy his
crazy hair and everything and I think I
I think I need to retire the the cage
image that I had as a youth let's talk
in the positive and not the negative
what is your favorite of the Nicolas
Cage movies I think gosh I mean that you
know his earlier ones obviously raising
Arizona and I love honeymoon Vegas I
love vampire's kiss I love his I just
love his like his cadence I love that it
feels like he crossed out all the
punctuation and sort of threw away even
with the language mint and just hears
like sounds like an autistic just the
way it is a very he has a very unusual
delivery and he's not afraid to just go
for it yeah yeah you know like there's a
in in vampires kiss there's a part where
he recites the entire alphabet and I
remember thinking as kids like that
that's the best acting of all time if
you can recite the alphabet and still be
interesting it's that's the key and like
he's talking about like filing something
to like a psychiatrist and and he's like
he's like you have to put it in the
right file you know according to
alphabetical order you know hey
QRS TUV wxy Z
[Applause]
that was not there's no way that was in
that was in the script but now no he his
most one of his most famous movie is
Wicker Man is this web online sensation
people talk about Wicker Man
yeah they even tell what Wicker Man is
really about I don't know either I I
know that I mean I know it there's human
sacrifice women taking men burning them
to attract bees and honey and I don't
know it just ends there same old story
that Hollywood tells over and over yeah
yeah it's screenwriting 101 I don't know
he yeah he yells the climax is like what
what was all for honey yeah yeah to my
grave I want that to be my last words on
her it was his and then the movie my
family will be so confused yeah Conan's
passing I think he has one last he was
in a coma but he came out just to say
this yeah honey it was all for honey now
obviously you you you're quite talented
at impressions you're good at
impressions how did you get into
impressions in the first place do you
remember um I first realized I might
have an ability here yeah I think I mean
I think I was like 11 and I liked I like
these I like this girl and I went on
sort of a double date to her house to
watch a movie and they put on sliver
which is a Billy Baldwin Sharon Stone oh
yeah yeah and so one of the girls is
like you know like he's cute or whatever
I was just trying to hold her hand I
couldn't even pay attention in the movie
but she was talking about Billy Bob
instead he said he was cute and then she
said you can look like him and I was
like really and I went home and I was
like I will look like I must so I went
home and I just figured out that all he
ever did was
[Applause]
I think we have a photo that I always
keep on hand let's see this foot screen
here
[Applause]
yeah if I heard rodents getting into my
trash and I shined a flashlight that's
what I would see I went back to school
and I was like hey it's me remember
forever how'd that work did she like you
know she was she who was Billy Baldwin
no so yeah that was that that was once I
had that groundwork laid it yeah I
everything else was yeah yeah and I
guess I started to figured everyone
someone said you kind of look like this
person I thought I guess I have to know
how to do yet down yes and I someone
told me I look like Ben Stiller and so I
figured out I was like all right I I
guess he's just a lot of like whoa whoa
whoa
[Laughter]
[Applause]